yo what up my people it's your boy
Davido and you can catch me live on the
bootleg cab podcast keep a lock on love
bootleg Kev show we got a special guest
the legend is in here man David oh
welcome sir wow you said it perfect
did I yeah because people usually [__]
it up yeah I'm not gonna lie I was a
little confused like like early on I was
like is it Davido is it Davido yeah it's
David oh yeah okay thank you big fun of
your show appreciate it man thank you
for having me you're obviously a legend
man I think when we think of like
afrobeats you're kind of like the Jay-Z
of this [__] okay you know crazy God is
good yeah what's it like to kind of see
your sound that you've been doing for
all these years become like
the sound now you know like you know I
was born in Atlanta you know what I'm
saying okay I've always been like coming
to America but like when I became a
musician especially like coming out here
you know for shows trying to push the
music it really just started with like
just like African fans coming to the
shows right you know when we do shows
out here and then it started just you
know spreading you know like even when I
was in college and I used to play my
friends African music and they liked
where'd you go to college in Alabama
okay you know what I'm saying which
which school it's called Oakwood
University okay it's uh something he was
raised in the South low key yeah yeah
yeah fully you know I'm saying so even
when I used to play African songs for
them I knew that they liked it so I
always knew it was always if there was
an opportunity to be heard you know
people you know [__] with it what's it
like uh because I feel like I don't I
didn't know that about you that you were
kind of you're from Atlanta and you were
you went to college in Alabama yeah
that's like the Bible Belt for real
crazy Huntsville Alabama Huntsville yeah
young I was like 60 years old in college
you know HBCU and that's coming like
straight from Lagos right you know
straight there and I remember even just
being in college
and talking to like friends there
they're asking me like oh how so how is
it in Nigeria like right how did you get
here y'all got airports you know what
I'm saying because they were not
educated about it about what's going on
yeah but now you know so you have social
media so it's different they see a
different side of Africa when you when
you tell people like oh I'm Nigerian
you're like oh I love afrobeats you feel
me yeah like 15 years ago that was not
the story you know what was like for you
like can you can you kind of pinpoint in
your opinion as somebody who you know
obviously has a crib out here and went
to school out here and was born here can
you kind of pinpoint the moment that you
noticed
like America starting to kind of take a
liking to the genre
from Atlanta Two Cities Atlanta New York
uh Millie Atlanta you know just like
even going out you know I'm saying like
like one thing I knew one of my friends
used to do he used to he was a big
baller he would go to the club and he
like spent so much money but he tell him
every time you know when you bring my
bottles out I want to hear this song
right you know what I'm saying so
the DJ's playing it you know I'm saying
the bottles coming out to the song you
know and the DJ is liking the music yeah
and then that's that was like one of my
first experiences of like being in the
club and hearing it yeah and then you
know it started growing you know once
the girls like it once the girls like it
it's over it's over you know what I'm
saying so even like girls being in
recovery with a guy like yo can you play
some white probation like
because you know girls like it right you
know let's do it it obviously we can't
because it was like a big big thing in
the UK first right no it was from the UK
yeah before you go to America you know
UK was like the first place to
acknowledge afrobe is like we started
doing Arenas in the UK first crazy you
know what I'm saying afrobeats UK
actually named that in afrobeats so
that's like a UK it's like an UK turn
but then you know we just ran with it
you feel me that's fire man what how
much um can you attribute to Drake
embracing it to kind of it being like
easily bridged to the U.S because I feel
like once Drake Gets behind anything for
the most part it can it can really take
off I mean there's this
there's like oh you know I'm saying
afrobeats was was definitely you know
I'm saying huge it was huge because if
it wasn't he was Drake Drake one the
[__] yeah he was like before Drake but
you know Drake is Drake right you know
what I'm saying so I'd be lying if I
said you know so he didn't put some
Spotlight to you know afrobeats you know
what I'm saying um and you know it was
dope he's made some dope you know
records yo there's this like new trend
where there's the normal version of a
song and then the sped up version back
in the day I mean you're from the south
you know there was this Chopped and
Screwed [__] the screwed up [__] back in
the day shout out to Texas but now I
feel like every single there's like the
normal version and then they got the
special oh that's crazy you said that
because I released the album was out so
we released a couple songs then we
released the single again with a sped up
version yeah there's a sped up version
yeah it's crazy you know what I'm saying
um
I don't know some songs I don't even
know like some songs I see on like Tick
Tock and stuff you don't even know the
normal version yeah I'd be thinking
that's that's the original when they
went ahead I'm like
oh okay it makes sense now I mean
social media is crazy though like it's a
different avenue when I started music we
used to talk about radio and you know
not now is like podcasts
if you're promoting me before but just
publishing on like YouTube Facebook
right now you got like 20 apps yeah that
you know you gotta do your promo I know
I keep hoping that Tick Tock gets banned
so I don't have to worry about it
anymore it's like one last day last day
I might give Tick Tock it's banned it
just takes one more thing I don't have
to worry about a way it was going crazy
yeah yeah are you pretty big on Tick
Tock
um I mean I got a lot of followers but
I'm not like are you like on the app
scrolling and like diving into the
algorithm no no no no because it'll suck
you in bro yo and every time I get on
Tick Tock I'll be there for like two
hours yeah cause whatever you're into it
knows yeah different and it's
everything's on there because I just
love like dogs and food so it just shows
me puppies and food and then it's crazy
how it can tell what you like yeah just
like being on the app after like a week
yeah it's like me I like food all those
cookies yeah just like guys who like
cooking a minute and like they're like
outside yeah oh yeah I love that [__]
and then I just bought a grill like a
griddle like a little Griddler thing
outside so like I'm like I'm always
trying to find like [__] to do on the
grill see the guy that throws the butter
on the thing no but a pot and butter
babe
yeah
his food
you ever see the uh the guy who does the
shark bite at the restaurants shark bite
big Groove I think he's African too
funny he might actually I interviewed
him
um I think he might be I think so it's a
guy's just a massive human being and he
does his stuff and he wears tattoos very
tight clothes you got to get him to do
to do a dance to yourself
um how give me kind of like your come up
because if you're in the stage you're
going to college here how to how do you
end up popping off you go back home yeah
um you know just being in Alabama for
like before I go to college obviously I
hardly liking to music of course well
because he like you know my father was
just adamant about me going to school
right you know I'm first generation
Entertainer in my family
you know so it's a little harder to
convince your everybody's hearing this
business business be like hey I want to
do this and they're like well it's a
normal template no you know I'm saying
you go to school and then you go out and
work for the family business right and
I'm the last kid of five so it was
already I was not even thinking about
you know convincing anybody or right so
you know just being in school
in Oakwood Oakwood was apart from me
it's a church it's a Christian School
right so apart from people like going to
church the choir so there are lots of
like musicians around the school so the
dude that live like they stayed like on
top of me in the dorm
it was like a gospel singer's name is
jamo so I always used to hear like music
musical ideas like but I never went to
check so one day I just said you know
let me go check somebody to check them
out to the door
and then he opens his room and it's a
whole studio setup
like in the dorm so I'm like she's just
recording himself yes so that was like
my first time like seeing like a laptop
studio equipment yeah yeah so I was like
yo how much is all this he told me I was
like yeah I want to buy it just teach me
the way around it so he was he he was
teaching me and I also like learned off
YouTube
YouTube University man you can learn
anything on YouTube so
um what was your first interface was it
like a Scarlet oh M Audio the little
Mbox yeah plug and play um USB and then
I had um the uh well it was it wasn't
Pro Tools it was logic logic yeah a lot
of people learn on logic yeah so from
there I just started recording myself
recording myself but mind you
you know like I said it's cool you know
what I'm saying so I I'd go home every
December right Christmas so
one December I go to the club
and it's like you know before before I
left in the club or on the radio in
Nigeria they play mostly American Music
like what was popping in Nigeria when I
left when you're in school
like 50 Cent of course yeah they love
him I feel like the world loves 50. 50
is just like anywhere in the world Yeah
Usher you know so that's like
confessions
then but you know I thought I'd you know
noticed that when I got back I thought
you know I think I was like two years
away and I came back for Christmas I
know it's like yo it was all African
music now blah blah it's different yeah
I'm in the club and I'm seeing like the
artists blowing up the girls going crazy
so I'm like
yo this is about to be something you
know what I'm saying right were you
already making that kind of music in
your dorm or were you trying to rap or
what were you doing no you know I
actually started as an engineer okay you
know what I'm saying so you were just
learning your way around yeah I used to
record like my cousins got you know and
stuff like go to Atlanta record them so
I actually started as an engineer
um so it was really like r b ish kind of
music right African music sometimes but
then when I after that trip changed it
changed it so when I got back it was
just
African music like after that trip I
decided that's when I decided like I
want to be a African musician so the
biggest artist at that time
his name was dibanj right
so anytime like Nigerian artists anytime
they're coming to Atlanta they would
always call me up you know hook them up
give them some e right you know what I'm
saying you're with the plug yeah and I
was like 15. 15 just selling weed in
Atlanta I wasn't selling we do I knew
where to get it yeah you know where to
get it of course yeah you know and you
were you were the middle man yeah I knew
where to get it so
you know from there you know I'm saying
they came so one trip one of the biggest
artists at that time came to
um
Atlanta I took them out you know got
them hotels
um took them to the strip club which one
uh then
some strip club on the south side I
think it's called Club wax okay it's old
so not Magic City not not Magic City so
I took them to that club box and yo
they changed like twenty thousand in
ones bro that's like the most money I've
seen right at that time I'm like what
you know these guys are really getting
it so at that point I was like yo I'm
not going back to school I wanna I wanna
I see that you can make some real money
off yeah and then then I was like yo
this is what I want to do
because like it's got to be kind of hard
because you probably were like also
semi-influenced by a lot of what was
going on in Atlanta and like it's kind
of hard to like see outside of what's
happening right in front of you so for
you to go back home during the summer
and be like oh no there's this whole
other yeah thing going on you know like
there's a there's another world outside
of the US yeah and I'm like um I don't
want to miss this you know what I'm
saying so that's when I like started
getting involved in doing I mean like
African music production facing it the
full week it wasn't even affecting my
academics you know what I'm saying once
you drop out uh after like two years I
dropped out parents were happy or they
were like they didn't know they even
know I was dropped off so you like they
thought I was in school you helped for a
year you're like school's good yeah
everything's going great sending them
fake grades on that you know what I'm
saying but it was the first combo where
you like let them know like it was never
a combo oh okay they just like saw you
on TV one day
so I you know he was calling my phone
okay and at this at this point I've got
him back to America but I was planning
to go back to Nigeria to start my music
career because like I had met people
already and stuff like that so um my
sister hit me up on Facebook
she's like I think my dad was like
trying to call my phone then he called
the school I'm not trying to reach me
and they're like oh uh Dr adeleke sorry
David hasn't hasn't been in the road
here for the past year so he's like what
what did my sister I'll never forget
that message I was eating a burger
dad knows you haven't been in school my
stomach oh [__] [__] your whole Bible
everything your dad's a doctor no no but
he got a like a doctor he's got a doctor
yeah okay
yo what up just boot like Kev we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie that's right so many
ways you can gamble with my bookie right
now man of course you got NBA playoffs
Western Conference Finals Eastern
Conference Finals they're set I love
Celtics versus Lakers in the finals all
right you can sign up at mybookie.ag
right now using that promo code bootleg
and get a very generous first deposit
bonus that's right and they just got the
craziest like revamp of the online
casino it's like a Las Vegas experience
if you play cards Blackjack roulette uh
you shoot dice whatever it is they have
like live dealers handling it for you
wherever you're at you could be at the
airport and be playing [__] roulette
on your phone it's amazing mybookie.ag
sign up with that promo code bootleg
right now you can bet on Sports you can
do slots you could do Blackjack uh craps
whatever you're into mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg for that first deposit
bonus and it is a generous one also got
to give a shout out to our family at
King Palms shout out to King Palm man if
you only know about King Palms they're
our new sponsor on the bootleg kept
podcast and they got such a great
product the best thing about King Palms
is it's all organic man no tobacco in
these wraps they're straight Leafs and
the best thing uh about them is they got
this product
they're flavor terpene tips all right
you stuff them with your with your
product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
okay we got one right here we got one
right here all right
you stuff this with your uh premium
cannabis from Hardy in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpom.com promo code bootleg and you
can get 50 off of whatever you order at
kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kickpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev promo code bootleg cab not
bootleg bootleg cab kingpom.com half off
everything let's get back to the
interview I mean technically he's a
doctor he got a doctor after that and
then my dad like I like I hit to seem
disappointed in me like it could mess up
my whole vibe for sure so I was like man
I'm gonna go home I ain't even trying to
heal like where do I start from yeah
like how where do I start from so I was
like man I gotta blow up
that's the only way he's going to
forgive me so you did you wait to like
really oh yeah should I I would say no
no
he well kind of I was like about to blow
up and then he kind of caught me kind of
because I ran I kind of dipped so he was
looking for me for months and I was like
you're just on the run from your dad 16
I was like 16 at this time 16 on the Run
not on the run but you know oh you're on
the run for me from your pops for sure
and I went to London for like six months
and then my friend had the studio yeah
his house you're 16 at the time yeah
she's 16. you kind of ran away Loki yeah
so I was in my friend's house recording
you know I'm saying he had a studio in
London yeah so I recorded like 10 songs
right
so I had him with me you know what I'm
saying at least I have content from
whenever I'm ready to drop
so after I've been in London for like
it's me and my cousin be ready that we
both ran away
so it's like after I've been in London
for like six months you got a fake ID at
the time
I was just in my friend's house but you
know I had an American passport yeah so
I just you know which is good money
wherever you're at come on anywhere
um so after like six months I'm like yo
I did 10 songs I saved up a little paper
I'm like you know I'm going to Nigeria
you know to start my career you know I'm
saying get on the plane land and then
like my dad like caught me
um oh [__] somebody that got over the
plane he was waiting for you in Nigeria
yeah the immigration he's living Nigeria
like the Army immigration people just
grabbed me off the plane and took me
straight to him I'm shook like boy I got
an eye piercing
um lip person
um he's not [__] with you yeah he's
looking me crazy he's like what happened
to my son so you get in the car don't
forget to hold me bye
I
don't need anything from you
then we get home
and the whole time I ran away my dad
like cut everybody off like he the
honcho he take care of everybody
so he's like go and get my son oh no you
know my son no few people yeah nobody's
yeah everybody messaging me like boy you
better come back home I'm hungry yeah
you guys [__] up out here I swear
everybody caught everybody off like
that's like my aunties yo your dad
sounds like a g no he's a mafia
I go I get back home
and then I have my 10 songs right so I'm
just like you I want to do music so I'm
telling my siblings and then my dad was
just like look you know what I'm saying
you could you could have just came and
told me you know I'm saying like oh this
is really what you want to do right I
was like Dad I told you like 10 times
nah finish school
so he so I ended up like cutting the
deal he was like
him so he's like um so you got to go to
school I said okay but what's it for me
he said I mean he would build me a
studio
and give me some paper to like start off
my career so he helped you out yeah he
did so I had to go to school for like
every two weeks I had to be in school
well he should be like four hours away
oh [__]
what was what was the song that changed
your life
um probably my second single it's called
dummy doodle right
um so that's when like
I left school I was like because I was
on because you're like look it worked
I don't got to do this the first single
was all right you know what I'm saying
but the second one I was in school so I
I was only allowed to go to the city
every two weeks so I'll be in school for
like 13 days four hours away yeah 13
days and then on the fourth 14th day I
can go to the city for just three days
to do music or try to break your record
stuff like that so and I'm in school my
dad put me next to like the owner of the
school like I might be like he's like
he's like really like like he's got eyes
on you this is the door of the school
owner yeah this is my room so every day
you go to work keep knocking on the door
like hey you in there are you going to
class you know stuff like that but when
I had that second record my boy called
me he was in the city
he said it's lit I said what you mean
say he was in the club last night he
played the record everybody went crazy I
said are you sure because if I leave
this place I'm [__]
I don't know I'll never forget so I made
like a fake body in my room like under
the covers yeah oh I've done it yeah you
put you know how to do so you put paper
you stuff the jeans with shirts yeah I
covered it just did like that yeah
tipped he was caught on the way to the
four hours trip he called him I feel
like where are you what what is this
I said man uh I'm out I'm out so that
night we got to the city
and this this is like my Fest
time scene like any fame or any feeling
type of any importance of my music I
walked in the club boy
they knew who you were
I was like okay
so like and I was like that's like I'm
17.
so that record was like too big like it
blew up the whole country the whole
Africa like it was like really like
literally overnight success crazy the
other side like we all confused like
like we're not even prepared for what
came you know I'm saying I'm like oh
damn now I gotta go PR I gotta get
publish this yeah I gotta get a tour
manager I gotta get you know I'm saying
this that you know what I'm saying then
from there it was just on what's the
clubs like because I've heard that the
clubs in Nigeria are crazy wow but like
you've been to both the Atlanta side and
so for you like America they don't dance
yeah I was about to say that's the one
thing about here it's like you got pop
bottles and they stare at each other
well Nigeria while dancing sweating to
like 10 a.m just everyone's dancing
happy smiling crazy bottles everything
what about are there strip clubs in
Nigeria yeah what are the Strip Club
Vibes like compared to just like here
same thing and funny enough a lot of
like dancers fly from America
to go dance out there oh that's fine uh
so you got the new project out Timeless
uh for people who don't know man are you
very like aware of like your place in
like afrobeats history history when
people bring up the big three I think
it's like you whiz kid and burnably yeah
um definitely now like definitely away
because especially like
do you have some once you remember when
I told you that I was like an out I was
an outsider looking in when I went for
December right and I saw the Arts you
know when artists everybody was like in
one section yeah of course yeah and I'm
just looking like
I gotta get in the mix but I also like
came with like a vision
do you understand and I feel like that's
what helped me solidify my place in
afrobeats Jesus came with a vision I
knew what I wanted you understand
um I'm a producer as well so
multi-talented with the production I
already knew how I want everything to
sound do you understand
um and from there and then you know
shout out to my pops you know I'm saying
he shot my first video your dad shot
your first video I mean he paid oh he
paid for it okay I'm about to say your
dad is Talent he's got a doctorate he's
out here shooting videos so he shot my
first video so you know from then I kind
of like you know got you know
okay Tina continue the journey and you
know coming out here
it was very important for me to come out
here and you know especially when when I
did my first tour I used to live in
America yeah so it was very important
for me to figure out
I know that it gets to be listed how do
we do not sound like it's already
popping in the clubs
and then before you know it a major
label hit me up boom Sony you know what
I'm saying
and this is I've been doing music
already for like seven years right you
know what I'm saying I'm talking about
we like we like 60 records in at this
time wow 60 records in but the old
records is just starting to catch start
to catch yeah I feel like that's what
has been happening with a lot of that so
it was very difficult
for us you know artists because we're so
come we're so comfortable already you
know what I'm saying at that time I was
really making at least 150 200 000 a
show and then we have like that's death
and then we already setting out
um stadiums you know I'm saying 50 000
people and then you know there's the
other side of things but you want to
move music to the culture to pushing you
come out here and it's like the money
ain't the same no definitely no now it
is it is now yeah but like back then
like you got to kind of start from
scratch again right definitely not like
my first show my first show I think was
New York it was like Urban Plaza I think
something like that it was like a
thousand people and yeah I'm used to
doing like 50. yeah but over there but
you know that's how you know spreading
the music waking up for interviews right
you know what I'm saying doing promo
yeah
so you know when the major labels got
involved the afrobeats I felt like we
had the music but we didn't have the
structure right you know I'm saying now
you know there's a little bit of
structure all the labels right now in
Nigeria and so yeah no I know uh like a
shout out to my guy gazi I think uh
Empire's doing there a lot yeah a lot of
artists Sony a lot of artists under Sony
as well too yeah yeah uh who who would
you kind of consider to be like your
OG's in in this [__] because I feel like
we always hear about you burn a boy and
Wizkid but there's a whole generation of
guys prior to you guys that kind of laid
the groundwork right um I think
definitely the bench you know that's one
of the artists I saw I was told
so the big three then was the banj
Two-Face and it's a group it's twins
called P-Square so that was though those
were like rog's you know then those are
the people that made me
it's possible doing this yeah I'm doing
this you also have kind of became one of
like the main guys that like hip-hop
artists will tap into if they need a
verse or a hook I mean work with guys
like fabulous and go on and on who are
some of the well first of all being as a
a guy who went to college here was born
in Atlanta has there been a hip-hop
artist you've worked with where you were
like damn that's crazy I got a record
with this guy like this is crazy
definitely definitely it should be oh I
think well I mean I have a lot of you
know records I didn't have one with me
but one of the records I was like yo it
was nice oh when I got that Nazareth in
Hip Boy Studio like that was one of the
moments because my brother you guys met
him at his voice yeah he just came in
the room I was like what Ah that's what
he's like yeah man like he likes African
music I was like oh thank you thank you
thank you what you working on and he
just laid the verse of me and my boys
just looking because that was special to
me because my oldest brother Nick he was
a big Mass fan like that Illmatic album
Still A man Stillmatic of course when he
was young in his face yeah illmatics
right there it's behind that box oh wow
see yeah that's crazy so that was like
crazy to me and then obviously like with
Thug you know yeah baby oh that was real
dope ain't no we connect to the vibe you
know you ended up connecting and like
really vibing with Doug yes oh
like not even on music tip you know I'm
saying Thug is Thug's a great guy man I
actually met a little baby through Thug
before a little baby even dropped a
record oh really she's back in the day
people don't understand like Young Thug
and Gucci are like two of the best a RS
ever because they just always have like
just Talent around him like and and we
all we'll all be in the studio and you
know when when you're like in the studio
and everybody's like playing their music
everybody passing the aux cord where I
put I play my
he always loved it so I always knew that
man this genre is going to go it's gonna
go
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a blue to it it's a chewable you
know what I mean anyway also got a shout
out to our family at Odd Socks don't
forget go to oddstocksofficial.com promo
code bootleg save 20 off man they got
the underwear that they just dropped uh
last year that's amazing so not only do
you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is what I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
optoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview
yeah that's got what was it did when you
guys worked together did he record the
verse with you there yes because I heard
his process is pretty crazy yeah he
he um Thug duty of a baby I said I sent
this baby that's all because like this
Thug don't write nothing down right it's
just does he lay the uh he lays he lays
the melody first and then punches inches
in and then go back punch in go back do
the melody then you you know you get the
words then you record it you know I kind
of record the same way too so you're
you're kind of similar you're laying
Melody down and then fill in the lyrics
Melody then filling the lyrics oh yeah
you used to be an engineer yeah which
way do you prefer to record an artist
because I do know some Engineers that
get frustrated we're like yeah punch me
in bad back no no right there punch me
and punch me think about me you got to
be quick because I get anxiety when you
know when you have an engineer recording
you they got to be fast yeah you have to
be very very quick and I don't sleep so
it's like you got to be quick quick
because you know when you want to you
know laid out an idea you know first of
all you don't want to lose it right
because sometimes it never comes back
you know what I'm saying so I like to be
kind of quick yeah for you uh how much
how much like of your own production are
you doing these days none actually none
yeah recently but
um with this last album
um I like I supervise the production
right I'm saying but I'm not as Hands-On
as you know I was you know years back
um what it's like for you give me two or
three artists that are on the come up
right now that we should be checking out
in the states like African artists yeah
um I was something but they big already
see what he said on the come up oh I
mean [__] maybe here definitely okay
he's he's hot right now I'm going crazy
yeah the highest ever the number one
song right now Rhythm radio yeah Selena
it's crazy
um
I've heard I've heard of bonjour yeah so
who's on the remix of that song
um
kiss Daniel
a lot of people man I can I can name a
hundred females you know we got Thames
we got iron star tiwa Savage so yeah
we're doing great do you ever like uh
see American artists trying to do what
you guys do and it it comes I've seen a
lot of guys do it and it's very corny
yeah but do you ever like feel like
like it's a little kind of appropriating
like y'all's Vibe because it does feel
like I've seen I mean I want to say
names there's been a few guys who've
like just blatantly just I mean like
they don't care about the culture
they're just like this is the sound let
me make the song you know I mean I don't
feel like offended by it like because
I'm from both worlds right but it'd be
like kind of weird when we have like a
session
and like and they come and they're like
yo can you make it sound like that I
said I'm like what are you talking about
yeah yeah like can you make it sound
like this okay you you've had that
happen yeah plenty of times do you like
to pull the guy to the side and be like
hey man like
you gotta appreciate what we're doing
here a little bit this is a microwavable
[__] yeah and then I'm just happy like
the narrative is changing and I've been
in the studio I've worked with so many
people and then you know what I'm saying
like before it was like a thing to have
like American artists on your record
it'd be like a big deal a big deal now
it's kind of the other way coming for it
you know I'm saying I don't mention
names but I'm saying
you can be in the studio vibing out with
somebody somebody do a verse the next
day they send you papers or invoice
yeah I thought well this was some that
you know in the video you gotta do that
too and you feel like it's the other way
around now what's up [__] I'm charging
now yeah yeah what you need I'm charging
now I'm sending my lawyers what's the
feature cost right now [__]
it's Timeless six figures
hundred hundred if I if I know you if
you if I know you that's the price if I
know you're 100 and that's not bad and
in the video and then the video cost
that's one thing like you know like
there's a few guys who like I feel like
but to be honest if I know that if we do
a record and I know that you're gonna
push it right to the Village to the
fullest and you're an artist that I
enjoy like if you're a fan of somebody
I'm a fan like me and Chris every time
we get in the studio like I'm happy you
know what I'm saying because Chris is
doing a video with You Chris is bring
you out on tour he's the best Chris is
thinking of ideas and he's also like our
our Michael Jackson yes like I think
Chris Brown's like he's an alien for you
uh because I do I do feel like there has
been a few artists who have kind of like
embraced like I know when Casanova free
Casanova came to Nigeria he went to
Nigeria video felt like he just died
little baby came tonight he stayed in my
house when he came tonight a little baby
baby was at the crib yeah
um the Migos came out there a lot of
people come out there for shows yeah I'm
curious like is the breaking an artist
process how much different is it than
here because here it's like
obviously there's Tick Tock now but you
know traditionally in hip-hop you would
want to maybe catch a wave in a strip
club first or you know there might be no
from like my generation it was like you
have to really like print out like a
thousand CDs go around the club but now
like
[__] is different you can be sitting
somewhere in the village you drop a
record once one thing goes viral and
it's over you know what I'm saying so
stuff is different now like even when
we're in the studio now we thinking like
yo how can we make a challenge to this
song like like how do we get this [__]
popping on Tick Tock and then out there
is audiomax really big oh dude I think
I'll do American yeah because you know
it's easy to it's easier it's like
subscribe yep yep you know what I'm
saying but recently Spotify Nigeria has
recently come to Niger and that's helped
a lot too who would you want to do a
collab project with from the states if
you could do a collab album with anybody
definitely Chris that'd be crazy
definitely Chris me and Chris got like
10 songs like people ain't heard 10 that
are just on a hard drive yeah
have you guys talked about doing that he
did a thug album definitely not
definitely
um I go to his house after here too but
yeah me and Chris definitely you know
I'm saying we I was implemented to go
and tour him you know I'm saying but
we're going to do a lot together who
else
um I do a record with scissor this would
be crazy this is really really dope I'm
looking for Bad Bunny too man
there is such a correlation between like
reggaeton and afrobeats because one it's
just great dancing music and I feel like
BPM wise like bpm-wise they match up so
well if you're DJing in the club yeah
have you done like any shows with any
like any like big reggaeton artists
anywhere um
no not really but I I had to show in
Puerto Rico though yeah crazy crazy I
remember on the flight Duramax my Angela
I was like are you sure it's gonna be yo
what it was like 20 000 people there in
Puerto Rico yeah [__] Puerto Rico we've
had um Mexico reach out to
um but I love performing on in the
islands all right what's your favorite
place to perform so far um so far that
was real dope I said the Bahamas the
Bahamas crazy do you ever go to that
crazy Resort they got there the Atlantis
Resort
we were like in and out in and out
records in and out records well look man
the new album's out right now Timeless
you know I'm saying going crazy
um
anything else on the way
um definitely be going on tour in July
you came everywhere
um no we do we splitting it up so we do
I want to see I want to go to I want to
go to a show that's not the United
States I want to go to like so come to
come to Niger I gotta go to Nigeria
Puerto Rico Rob
are we going to Nigeria yeah yeah we're
gonna get through December December
December
let's go
so the the best time to come definitely
you know in December you know I'm saying
you should also visit Ghana too I heard
God is amazing Ghana's dupe so Nigeria
is like New York right and Ghana is like
la
ah like okay calmer so Nigeria is like
fast paced bro you got to be sharp yeah
if you can't survive in Nigeria you
can't survive anywhere God is more
relaxed oh yeah kick back you want to
don't kick back too much in L.A though
they'll Rob your ass out here oh I know
you guys listen dude Africans claim Elon
Musk
because he is South African I'm just
wondering is it he's from yes
that's crazy he's got like kind of like
South Africa a lot of you know
Caucasians are down there you know what
I'm saying because um you know they
stayed after so South Africa South
Africa looks like L.A
it's like beautiful like is it that yeah
isn't it like very still kind of like
separated and like a lot of the social
issues yeah like this one yeah it'd be
weird like some Jim Crow type [__] going
on there they're like two languages I
know there's like one language called
Afrikaans right and like it's weird like
I think I'm not sure there's not 100 but
I think like the black people don't
speak that language that's wild man well
listen I appreciate you pulling up
you're definitely a ledger man it's dope
to have you here uh new album out new
album out Timeless unavailable Tour on
the way I got a Festival in Atlanta in
November oh [__] yes I plan to do it
yearly it's called a wave Fest who else
performing oh I'm trying to bring all
okay you're bringing everybody everybody
I'm trying to bring everybody through
and have like uh our own Coachella we
can do every year yeah I just saw
there's a big uh afrobeats Festival in
New York I think is Miami the next one
will be Miami okay yeah that's what's up
I appreciate you man yeah affirmation my
brother appreciate you man let's go
David oh hey we gotta wrap up an
interview brought to you by hardean Las
Vegas appreciate y'all watching hey
don't forget when you go to Vegas you
got to go to Hardee man it's the
craziest dispensary you'll ever walk
into it smells like [__] heaven in
there all right get in that Uber when
you hit Sin City tell them take me to
Jardine they're gonna take you you're
gonna get a wild selection of the just
top top of the line cannabis the best
selection you'll go uh be able to see in
the US Plus on top of that they got the
crazy gear they got the clothes they got
the bikinis they got a wonderful
selection of Bud tenders that are very
good at their job man they'll take care
of you tell them that bootleg have sent
you the bud tenders are Harding don't
know what that means they're gonna get
you hooked up right all right go follow
them online Harding underscore Las Vegas
or just go check out their website too
man hardinglasvegas.com and when you're
in Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real